اعلنت شركه الكهرباء الوطنيه في افغانستان
ان الكهرباء المستورده من اوزباكستان التي
تعد المصدر الرئيسي للطاقه في البلاد
انقطعت بسبب مشكله فنيه وقد غرقت العاصمه
كابول ونحو سبع مدن اخرى في الظلام بعد
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي ما تسبب في ارباك
الحركه في المصانع والمستشفيات وكان وزير
الخارجيه الافغاني بالوكاله امير خان متقي
قد طالب في وقت سابق حكومه اوزباكستان
بتوفير الكهرباء لبلاده بحسب العقد المبرم
بين الطرفين
[موسيقى]
معنى المنكوب المراسله الجزيره نصر شديد
اهلا بك ناصر الى اين وصلت ازمه انقطاع
الكهرباء ان كان في كابول ومدن اخرى ايضا
في افغانستان
نعم ازدهار منذ ثلاثه اسابيع هناك ارباك
كبير بنسبه للشعب الافغاني جراء عدم توفر
الطاقه الكهربائيه لعموم افغانستان خاصه
في فصل الشتاء طبعا نعلم ان افغانستان
هناك بين 75 الى 80% تستورد الطاقه
الكهربائيه من دول الاجواء الجوار خاصه
الاعتماد هنا في فتره الشتاء حيث تتجمد
الانهار الست بالاضافه الى طبعا هناك
عشرات الانهار الفرعيه لكن جراء الطقس
البارد تتجمد هذه المياه ولا تستطيع ان
تولد الكهرباء من السدود ان كانت سدود
رئيسيه او سد بالقرب من بعض الكره التي
تستفيد من الطاقه الكهربائيه الوضع سيء
للغايه منذ تقريبا ثلاثه اسابيع والشعب
الافغاني من يعني قله توفير الكهرباء في
منازلهم نحن الان في احد الشوارع الفرعيه
في الحي الدبلوماسي في وسط العاصمه كابول
في وزير اكبر خان نسمع بعض اريكم بعض
الصور هنا لمولدات كهربائيه ضخمه
لبعض المنازل بالاضافه الى اشتراك بعض
المنازل في هذه المولدات
لتوفير الكهرباء الذي التي تنقطع عاده
يعني نحو اربع ساعات الى خمس ساعات في
توقيت محدد بالاضافه الى احيانا عندما
كانت الازمه الكهربائيه شديده قبل اسبوعين
بالذات الان هناك بعض التخفيف لكن لا زالت
هناك اشكاليه كبيره فقط كانت الكهرباء
تاتي الى المواطنين فقط نصف ساعه في اليوم
لكن هذه الامور ربما لم تتمكن الحكومه من
الانتهاء من
تعاقدها او لنقل المخالصه بينها وبين
جارتها
اوزباكستان التي توفر نسبه كبيره من
الطاقه لافغانستان نعلم ان افغانستان
تستورد من جاراتها اوزباكستان تركمانستان
طاجكستان بالاضافه الى ايران الطاقه
الكهربائيه على الرغم من انها من الممكن
ومن السهوله عليها ان تولد الكهرباء جراء
توفر المياه مياه الامطار بشكل غزير وهناك
انهار لكن السدود لا تبنى بالشكل الجيد
وليست هناك خطه استراتيجيه منذ تقريبا
اربعين عاما
لحل مشكله الكهرباء هنا في افغانستان شكرا
لك من كابول مراسله الجزيره ناصر شديد